so thank you so much for letting me
speak and thank you so much for
letting us have this program uh
interesting as it's going to be given
all the situation but
it will be fun as always so uh
the program that we are planning to run
with alberta serious sambas
vijay ganesh and jakob norstrom
is satisfiability satisfiability theory
practice and beyond and i just noticed
that
being canada called adventure but you
could spring
oh yeah
so satisfiability is um
very kind of uh general problem you have
a bunch of constraints
stable and constraints and
you trying to find out whether it's
possible to satisfy them simultaneously
you write down the list of constraints
make it into a formula and ask if there
is a certifying
assignment for this formula
and this problem or significance of this
program and problem with celebrating 50
years
this year because
50 years ago steve cook's famous paper
kind of proving the satisfiability is
and be complete and
introducing the notion of
anti-completeness related and palatine
he didn't call it in the completeness
that was a couple years
after the scar showing that all sorts of
things are reducible to
satisfiability and uh
in from the theory point of view this is
considered to be an
ultimate heart and p-heart problem
uh with conjecture that we cannot be
brought for
search even by a little bit
people have shown that all sorts of
restrictions of this problem
like linear number of constraints
are still hard it's believed to be hard
on average
and we could show that for some causes
of algorithms
it is indeed hard on average
so it's an ultimate
and bihar problem and yet from the
practice point of view
as practitioners tell us it's an
ultimate easy problem because a lot of
time in industry when there is a
constraint satisfaction problem
the the way to solve it is well let's
code it up as a formula
and unleash a set sober on it
and miraculously it usually works
so let me just mention a couple of
examples
um for example when they run
fcc reverse auction to buy
broadband from tv companies
and sell it to mobile companies i think
it was
in 2015 they actually use the set solver
at an underlying engine in order to
figure out
to whom they can make lower offers
and interestingly enough there the
solver running time
directly translated into money because
if solver timed out they would decide
that there is no solution
and they have to pay uh whoever selling
it
whatever whatever they decided to pay
them so set solvers had
also been heavily used in hardman
software verification
air traffic control um
i think in london they use set solvers
to optimize the switches
on the railway networks all sorts of use
and it also had been used to solve some
mathematical problem
for example there was a result a couple
of years ago
by some people who will be at the
program
uh showing that um
it's impossible uh to
color integer so that
all the pythagorean triples are
monochromatic
starting from some pretty big numbers
seven thousand
something something and they actually
had the proof of impossibility which was
100
yeah so
the big question is why does it work and
that's what this work
this program is intended to look at
they're bringing together
practitioner nurse we're bringing um
together theoreticians from several
different areas
and we are going to try to understand
why this theoretically hard problem is
easy in practice
and how to leverage it to make solving
everyday problems better
and we'll be happy to run in parallel
with
tfcs program
which will also bring the syrian
practice together and moshe will talk
about it next